It turns out that the bus travels at 50 miles per hour, and the van travels at
60 miles per hour. Great algebra solving if you got those two correct. We can
start solving this equation by multiplying both sides by the lowest common
denominator. That would be x times x minus 10. We're really just cross
multiplying, so we get 200x equal 240 times x minus 10. Next, we distribute the
240 to get this equation and then we subtract 240x from both sides. This leads
us to this equation which we can then use to solve for x. We just divide both
sides by negative 40. So we'll have 1x is equal to 60. Now that we've solved
for x, we want to remember what it actually represents. In this case we know x
was the speed or the rate of the van. So, we know the van speed is really 60
mph, and the bus's speed would have to be 10 less than that. So the bus
traveled at 50 mph.